compte tenu de leurs activités de leurs
contraintes ménagères dans un certain
nombre de cas vous pourrez résoudre
leurs problèmes en travaillant à
mi-temps ce qui ce se fait déjà et qui
pourrait être envisagé de se faire et
c'est la préparation par exemple à la
retraite n'est ce pas là de pouvoir
décrocher est passé delà de la période
professionnelle à la période
d'inactivité par une période à temps
partiel pouvons passer de trois quart de
temps habitants en matière de temps pour
arriver là la retraite
on peut imaginer et on peut très bien
organiser une usine avec une succession
de l'équipe de quatre heures n'est ce
pas au lieu de le faire
traditionnellement avec des successions
des équipes de huit heures dans la
mesure où c'est une organisation de
travail en double équipe